chaque année les oies sauvages embarque
pour la grande migration au dessus de la
chine sepang
il est un peu plus maladroit que les
autres au point de rater le grand départ
mais apparemment il n'est pas le seul
toit notre maman je t'aime maman j'ai ma
belle tu y es tu lui c'est mon petit
frère
alors on a été séparé de leur groupe tu
va nous aider ou pas n'entraîne pas les
producteurs de shrek est en route vous
présente un voyage hors du commun à
travers la chine a les boules tu n'as
aucun esprit de famille
c'est dégueulasse
cet été
accrochez vos plumes
ils sont partis dans le cadre
g
la tenture prend son envol
ça c'était hyper cool
le flip
fin août on serait effet moins des city
banyuls héros le trouvait derrière nous
destination pékin
bon
[Musique]
le 15 août au cinéma